ich möchte ich mit dem video einfach
sagen leute fähig diese ganzen menschen
die euch irgendwie erzählen wollen weil
er ein bisschen dicke backen hat nicht
werden willkommen zu einem neuen video
leute wie als youtube einer besonderen
positionen unter leute zu ihre
erfolgreiche youtuber ag nach dem erfolg
mit 1000 zehntausende hunderttausende
leute die ihm zuhören
romy interessiert was dazu sagen hat das
problem ist dass man sieht wie vor augen
hätten anstellen kann mit seiner
reichweite welchen positiven effekt man
kann ich habe mich ob man in jedem video
immer predigen kann wer letzten endes
müssen die videos aus haltern seien die
leute wohl noch einfacher bitten auf
malta aufgenommen werden ganz normal
aber ich würde heute gerne mal beim
thema reden hat mich schon länger
beschäftigt und wo ich bin freute sich
huber bringen möchte das thema
ästhetische lena mein körper oder
generell körper im allgemeinen ich habe
ich vor ein paar tagen oder freunde
unterhalten da habe ich nicht eine sache
erinnert die meine kleine schwester
gesagt mein vater sagt sie mit zwölf
wochen so viele gedanken darum dass hier
irgendwelche schönheitsideal entspricht
wenig aussieht wie irgendwelche model
und ich weiß nicht was zu gerne
es tut mir in der seele weh zu sehen wie
junge menschen von sosa unter diesem
schönheitsideal druck leiden dass ich
mich dass heute mal in den bio
thematisieren filiale erste fall
wirklich verlangen für sportler in einer
woche warten ob du dich dazu speziell
ernähren größte liebe lisa seine
schützlinge frage ich versuche so weil
es drei wird maximal vier mal die woche
sport machen die macht gerne austausch
sporttest gegner laufen deswegen bin ich
per leben bisschen definierter wenn man
dich laufen einfach definieren körper
kommt jetzt eine gute kombination
krafttraining und ausdauertraining
kombiniert man einerseits muskeln
aufbaut anderer seite aber schlange oder
grip bleibt dadurch die von
ausdauersport mich nicht in der lehre
sagte ich fress einfach worauf ich bock
hat es ist so lächerlich leute ihr müsst
mögliche einfachen sport machen oder ich
halt nicht ordentlich der heutige
verwandte proteine reinbekommen ich
hatte nicht katastrophal überfressen
wenn wir auf jeden fall gute resultate
erzielen
ich bin eher jemand ich hab keinen bock
darauf ich mega frisch zu machen in der
karten gehen oder so das einfach nicht
mein ding ich will immer bedeutet sich
verrückt machen was irgendwelche waffen
gegeben aber nicht bereits im sport zu
machen in meinen augen
ist die nummer 1 sport das wichtigste
wenn man seinen körper verändern die
schwierige frage ich würde vielleicht
aber klagen mein bauch mitte wurde
erhöht ich meinen körper wohl ja du bist
ein paar dinge die wir meinen körper
noch verändern möchte ja definitiv auch
jetzt beispiel gerne mit mir mut gemacht
und noch ein bisschen mehr ausdauer aber
ich fühle mich in meinem körper sehr
wohl heute für mich einfach daran zeigt
dass ich am liebsten eigentlich ohne
klamotten schule einfach irgendwo ich
habe einfach irgendwie so ein brand ohne
klamotten rumgelaufen was wahrscheinlich
erste beweis dafür ist dass ich mich in
meinem körper wohl fühle
ich habe gar nicht zum kraft durch
getakteten mega professionellen
trainingsplan nicht mehr einfach so ein
bisschen jahres gelder aufzubauen musste
ihn zu halten ich hoffe es nicht negativ
strukturiert was ich immer machen
welchen fisch zu gewinnenden klimmzüge
nach möglichkeit breite klimmzüge aber
davon hätten bekommen berechtigt hätte
ich konnte eigentlich immer machen gibt
er zu zwei stangen und an den stangen
das darin oberkörper so runter durch die
wieder hoch runter hoch runter gemacht
die groß dass auf den trizeps also den
arm strecker und sogar eine aber
eigentlich finde ich dass menschen nicht
kennt nämlich abstoßend
okay die frage ist wie dich zu
schönheitsoperationen stehe ich bin ganz
gutes beispiel wie gesagt wohin david
wei für ihn david das vermutlich jetzt
einfach mal so schon relativ umoperiert
dass wenn man das so nennen möchte das
werk von der vermutung die für den raum
gestellt und ich weiß was mich ganz
genau ehrlich gesagt aber ich denk mal
wie gemacht ist vielleicht in die
machten hintern kiefer vor sondern
wichtig dass eigentlich ja auch nicht
schlecht aus aber die kraft und
attraktive sache daran ist für mich dass
man sagt okay ich mag meinen körper so
wäre nicht dass ich mich unters messer
riegel und ihm deswegen verändern lassen
den körper gefällt nicht dass ich nicht
wenn sie sport dahin bringen kann wo ich
ihn gerne haben möchte und mich jetzt
unters messer und hat mich irgendwie
auch schneiden das finde ich irgendwie
so richtig kraft eine krasse ablehnung
gegenüber dem eigenen körper ich bin
auch nicht gut aus
manchmal ist wirklich einfach ein paar
titel aber der gedanke den man dafür
braucht um dahin zu kommen
der pflicht so cool ja ja ja ja ja ja
ich bin manchmal bist lieb ich bin sehr
verliebt angereist aber auch wer wird
kritisch aber als diese momente da sich
vom spiegel stehe und mit dem popo geil
hier habe ich tatsächlich und es hat mir
auch viel damit zu tun dass mir
irgendwie zeigt dass ich es geschafft
habe dass ich meinen körper wie
verändert hat war ja keine kinder die
dick war bisher und das wird cool alle
clark junaid in meinem körper und fragen
wo ich schon mal hin reiten wollte uhr
super
[Musik]
verstanden
die frau hat mir gerade im schon mal
ganz ähnlich aber ich beantworte sie
trotzdem weil die nach dieser anregung
union hat und zwar auf sport mit spaß
macht und fordert macht mir wirklich
spaß
mittlerweile hat spaß daran gefunden mit
gewissen zu quälen dabei hunderte männer
auf ihre plakate zu sehen natürlich aber
gerade laufen ist und wegen dass mir
einfach wirklich spaß macht ich mag das
einfach so weiter ausgebaut ist und der
cockpit komplett abgeschaltet man rennt
einfach wie bewegt man sich durch die
pampas ich bin braune augen eigentlich
ganz gut also guck mal ich finde meine
augenpartie posten meinen haaren ein
verbot so richtig kraft blaue augen
findet ja auch ganz nah ist aber mit
einer korpulenten frau vorstellen könnte
definitiv ja ich würde auf gar keinen
fall sagen dass besagte
ausschlusskriterium ich hätte natürlich
auch einer der fußläufig machen kannst
du sagen absolut 38 geht gar nix aber so
dumm wenn ich nicht dass ich die
pauschale aussagen machen würde dabei
stützen endet immer davon abhängt wie
der einzelne mensch auf mich wirkt nein
ich wollte nur sagen dass ich ab und zu
meinen eigenen körper
[Musik]
das finde ich am schönsten seite was mit
dem hässlichen diese seite was mit
diesem video auch machen wollte was
nicht durch die fragen an sich
funktioniert über die feindlichen diese
richtung gehen ist einfach ein bisschen
auf dieses thema und zufriedenheit mit
dem eigenen körper auf dem land machen
die sache deute es gibt körpertypen die
tarifrechtlichen ungesunder sind meine
planung 80 kilogramm übergewicht hat
dann hat es tatsächlich gefährliche
einflüsse meine vielleicht erst
versagten ihre fertigen vertreten dort
aber wenn man sagen normalgewichtig ist
und vielleicht vom schönheitsideal wie
viel kilo zuviel hat dann hat man
eigentlichen passion und war die erste
ist man sagt videothek mit wirklich was
verändern und vergaben zum beispiel
sport machen sie anders zu ernähren oder
man sagt ja verbilligte macht auch mein
körper sowie erste hochlädt und das
finde ich viel gesünder wenn wir
wirklich eine rede welche wirklich viele
junge zuschauer auf paar junge mehr ist
die einfach ich weiß nicht ich finde es
so schade es junge menschen zu sehen die
nicht mit ihrem körper zufrieden
irgendwer ihnen sagt er hat immer
hässlich bin damit genau auf einen
treffer ich möchte ich mit dem video
einfach sagen leute liegt diese ganzen
menschen die euch irgendwie erzählen
wollen weil er ein bisschen dicke backen
habt nicht mehr fit die ohne hacker
mittels ging an die ihr seid auf jeden
fall okay so wie ihr seid wenn ihr euren
körper verändern wollte ist es auch
keine schande machen einfach ein
bisschen sport aber lasst euch auf gar
keinen fall einreden dass wir weniger
wert wird nur weil ein paar kilo mehr
als andere menschen wie gesagt die leute
die euch das erzählen wir sind absolut
gut so wie ihr seid und euch empfehlen
möchte dass sie weniger wert lag bei
dickeren bauch ihre beine oder dicke
backen habt ist ein kleiner moment
wirklich kleine kleine geboren wurden
das ist kein spaß heute wirklich klasse
gar nicht fertig machen aber du hast
mai können